- [Narrator] This is iPhone City
a Foxconn manufacturing
campus in Zhengzhou ,China.
With a population of as much as 300,000,
the size of Pittsburgh.
The facility at one point made 85%
of the pro lineup of iPhones,
but now that's starting to change.
Other Foxconn factories like
this one in southern India
have been tapped to build iPhones.
And facilities like this
one in Vietnam are expanding
to produce other products
that were once mainly made in China.
That's because protests
at the Zhengzhou factory
a wave of infections and
three years of Covid woes
in China, have helped propel
Apple to look for alternatives.
But supply chain analysts
say China's finely tuned
production system won't
be easy to replace.
So here's why Apple and its
suppliers face an uphill battle
when it comes to building
new iPhone Cities in India
and Vietnam.
Over the past two decades
Apple has looked primarily to Foxconn,
the world's biggest electronics
manufacturing company,
to turn its product designs into reality.
Since it first began
making iPhones in 2010
Foxconn's facility in
Zhengzhou has stood out
for its efficient ecosystem.
It excels at collecting the
hundreds of required parts
from manufacturers, and
assembling the functioning devices
to be shipped out to customers.
Supply chain analysts say,
China has been the best at this
because many of these
parts and the metals needed
to make them, are refined
and built within the country.
But assembly plants in India and Vietnam
won't have such easy
access to these components.
According to its latest list of suppliers
Apple works with more than 180 companies
and about 150 have operations in China.
Just compare that to Vietnam
where only 26 Apple
suppliers have operations
while India only has 11.
That means assemblers in these countries
would have to import
more of the parts needed
to make Apple products,
a process with plenty
of paperwork and delays.
Once the parts arrive,
factories need a lot of workers
to assemble the many components
that go into Apple products.
To maintain having hundreds
of thousands of workers
in iPhone City in Zhengzhou,
Foxconn provides onsite accommodation
that has allowed workers
from all around the country
to live and work at the factory.
But India's Foxconn factory where Apple
is now building new
iPhones from the beginning
of their production cycle
is much smaller with fewer workers.
So the company busses them
in from nearby hostels
and villages that are mostly
within a 50 mile radius.
Analysts say to meet
this increasing demand
Foxconn's factory in India may eventually
meet the type of on-campus
accommodation seen in Zhengzhou.
Apple and Foxconn did not
respond to requests for comment
about the challenges facing
facilities in India and Vietnam
such as import delays
and workforce shortages.
In Apple's April earnings
call, CEO Tim Cook
said the company's continuing to optimize
the production process.
- [Tim] Our supply chain is truly global
and so the products are made everywhere.
- [Narrator] Even though Apple
is starting to look elsewhere
analysts say it's unlikely
to completely leave
China's efficient system anytime soon.
Production started to recover
after Foxconn lifted COVID-19 restrictions
at its Zhengzhou plant in early December.
And wait times for high-end
iPhone models have improved.
Still, people involved
in Apple supply chain
say the company may
look to other suppliers
within China to reduce
its reliance on Foxconn.
That may mean in the future a wider range
of companies will be
building more of our iPhones
and other Apple products.
(upbeat music)